just a lot of short jokes and I tell one
story at the end which is about a
vigilante who saved me in Cleveland
really yeah hilarity oh they're great
club yeah what happened basically a
Valentine's Day LeBron adjust left the
Cavs Oh Cleveland was [ __ ] angry they
were and they desert they put everything
on LeBron that city so yeah but by the
way if I'm LeBron I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of Cleveland I like the people but
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of Miami even
clearly yes I do you think even
Cleveland nurse even clue the guy goes
you like Cleveland I go yeah any
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ] likes Cleveland
and walked away from me now where do I
go they go well there's a market if you
just you could go over the like ten
minute ride this market yeah so market
and that was it yeah market or do you
want to [ __ ] Cuban models for an entire
basketball season you're going Miami are
you gonna [ __ ] Miami but so uh yeah
basically I met a girl after the show
and and she was there with a guy but
they weren't dating and we kind of hit
it off and he was buying me drinks to
keep an eye on hey so I was like all
right whatever
I'll he'll take the free alcohol and
then he left for a second I just asked
you do you want to leave and we left and
we start making out and like on the
street then we end up in a bar we're
doing shots good night yeah night for a
comic it's good night and then I was a
feature too so it was even better even
better
I was headlining like an off night you
know all on your funny [ __ ] alright Keep
Calm so sleepy you look a little bit
like a sleepy look like a thinner who
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] was the quarterback
for the Falcons oh oh no I never get him
I would get Flacco for the raid gets way
[ __ ] yeah Co people would say Michael
Michael Phelps but not the bottom
[ __ ] I know not the body's not a
good looking guy he's good I know that
he comes now you're a good-looking guy
thank you there he is there's Flacco
right there you are that's exactly why
men got good hair though look at that
hey you have your ears all right it's
very Italian and curly or as a Jewish
I'm a Jew yes your juice is that but you
like a Jew who looks a little bit
Italian but then you look at your hair
and you're like well I mean Flacco yeah
Flacco that's the
that's the Italian version if Flacco was
a Joey be you and that's the Italian
Cohen a Jew Italian is almost a
compliment because it just means that
we're not neurotic
well the Jews always the Jews would
always play Italians in the mobster
movies back to ya
so James Caan played Italians James Caan
who's the Jew who played the Mexican and
the good the bad and the ugly
you know Eli Wow yes [ __ ] Eli Wallach
good call on Eli Wallach
that's right lives like 99 yes indeed
yes he [ __ ] did you yes I did he went
to my acting school dance he was a great
actor and he said to me he goes do
everything do it all I don't give a [ __ ]
if it's on you know the and he was so
good he goes I don't care if it's on a
cruise ship I did everything and that's
what I did that was my mother I mean I
never forgot that I never said no to a
goddamn thing I did I did it all that's
so smart he was he was phenomenal he's a
great a great in that movie to look at
him back in the day you get they weren't
wearing sunscreen they were all sweaty
they were sweaty for [ __ ] real I mean
so adapter oh you're just like you just
like just Han a lot I'm playing to
Mexican that's it that's exactly right
just tan yeah so anyway I met that girl
in Cleveland it turns in like a whole
thing well I'm about to take her back to
the hotel and then the dude who we ditch
found us on the street and he was a
scary dude and he was like missing a
couple teeth I was like he's gonna
[ __ ] I can't fight dude I just can't
all you la comics can fight all this New
York comics are drunks and we're [ __ ]
you know what I mean like all you la
comics are black belts and shit's
hilarious like yeah you're all like I
know you're a badass
I mean I'm not a badass but I'll fight I
mean in that situation I'm probably
gonna be I'll be hopefully better than
oh I don't know I just I don't know I
don't know I do fight this guy might
have a knife I don't want to get [ __ ]
stabbed or somebody so I was just like
he's got in my face was like you wanna
you want to go back I I asked her like
what do you want to do and he just kind
of was like do you wanna do you want to
fight over and I was like no well you
know yeah but they're not situation I'd
be like no I was in I was in Dallas that
all I was doing was talking to a girl
who was talking to me she was talking to
me and I was alone I wasn't doing
anything and she started talking to me
and the boy she was with the guy she was
with took her beer I ran and
smashed it on the ground I didn't miss a
[ __ ] beat I literally turned I just
it went and I just turn and walk the
follow I just turn and walk away I
disappeared in the crowd I'm not gonna
move I'm not gonna [ __ ] fight over
any Carl no I mean that I that I just
met or who's talking to me now that's
Alana says missing - he was missing
teeth noise I've never [ __ ] someone
had been like that was better than teeth
yeah that was a lot you know it's
exactly right it's just not yeah I got I
had a thing in Vermont this is another
story from the special but it's just you
made me think of because there's a plank
the the beer glass some mash and a guy
smashed a beer glass over my head in
Vermont last year you don't seem like a
bed you seemed very unassuming nice I am
I did nothing
what happened was I wasn't even at the
show I was two blocks away having a beer
with a friend of mine Carmen lagana a
comic who's opening for me that show and
we're in the we're in the bar and this
guy just walks up to me and he just kind
of started [ __ ] and I was just kind of
like okay I was ignoring him and
something was off about him I could tell
and he and he just do two of the comics
there and he said he said you go to he's
a university or from Vermont I said no
and he goes do you have a master's
degree you know I said you're getting
colder it's what I said to him and he
said I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of all
of you and I just like kind of turned
away I was like he's not gonna actually
hit us I just kinda like he's bluffing I
turn away he took a pint glass and just
smash it over my head and I turned
around like it kind of in shock I was
like what do I do
oh you know so there's two other guys
here who will fight I know they stood up
for me I'm always getting ready for that
moment and there's no way I would have
turned around I would have gotten I
would have gotten position that is why I
box and do jiu-jitsu at 53 because I
still feel like I gotta be ready
you're 53 yeah [ __ ] I know it's
ridiculous you look you look not 53 like
hearing that I'm not in New York 53 but
if you lived in Cleveland right now you
look like [ __ ] oh yeah it's LA I'd be
hunched over my back but I also work out
like if I'm a mess I work out I still
train that's all
you look amazing 4:53 holy [ __ ] thank
you sir
that's insane like that
not bad not bad
I thank you well the guy anyway I found
out he he's you know he's a therapist
the guy who smashed a bottle of the
Penguins in my head he's a therapist he
his wife had just left him I could I was
talking to the victims ad I hate that
[ __ ] word to the victims I'm a victim
but uh the victims advocate in Vermont
and she called me and he went for the
cops gone when the cops got him
so that he was hoping the cops would
shoot I he was trying to die but so now
it's like a felony in it and they were
like do you want to come out he was like
I'm not gonna come out there [ __ ] the
deal with this guy I think I was having
a moment he was he was having a moment
of madness I'm not gonna there's not a
shot I get on two planes to go you know
testify no first time I feel like a
[ __ ] second of all just not doing it I
turned my back my bad
that's how I hunted through my bag no I
I am I
that's literally I'm always ready for
that I mean I I yeah I could that's
amazing that I get angry though that's
what it is a guy in Edmonton punched me
ain't like this and smacked my face but
he was doing it like he was alpha in me
who he was big and he was with his group
and I could tell you the Alpha and he
was him a pop Bob and one like that and
I had been working on on this crack Oh
move this gray where you reach up daniel
cormier I did it to to Frank Mir and I
wanted to know how to do it my friends a
wrestler
so I read I got on the hooks I grabbed
him like this and I I i did this what's
called a knee pick I don't even know how
to well I would just was I'd practiced
it because I'm that much of a [ __ ]
idiot
and I went I ain't I pulled him down and
I and I let go as he felt I grabbed his
ear and I pulled his ear really hard Wow
all right and he fell into the waitress
and he got with three silver and then he
said um and he just was so in shock and
then I slapped him Oh
like I grabbed him and I slapped him but
I did it not in a way where it looked
like I was fighting him I did it in a
way where it looked like I was um like
it looked like I was doing it back to
him and I was just more I was aggressive
and I think I told I said something like
I said I think it's a thing really weird
like I'm a chimp because I felt like one
strong enough someone to be on a big
dude
well wasn't yeah he didn't expect you
know he was III you know but it was if
you had seen it you wouldn't have known
what I was quite doing he just didn't
know either but I slapped him I went
back back and I was ready to [ __ ]
yeah I was so mad but I was smiling and
I think I went my god bro careful and
then I walked away
he sent me drinks all night oh my
waitress I go I can't drink I can't do
this but so fill it with water or iced
tea
cuz he was sending me like he sent me
like a brown drink and I think it was
like Jameson's or some [ __ ] vodka or
tequila whatever the [ __ ] it was but he
kept sending me and I kept going alright
water anyway ever since we got that
story kind of Alfred you and you Alfred
him bag and then he took you glad you
got angry we've been working on this
particular move but you bullied a bully
you bullied a bully and then he and then
he turned nice that I [ __ ] hate that
about people
yeah but bullies make me he was just
being a he was being the alpha guy and
he was a big good-looking guy so I
already hated him for being bigger than
me and uh it's all insecurity for me I
just can't
I got Puli when I was in eighth grade
right I should I should have smashed a
pint glass over the guy's head back and
maybe he woulda bought me now have my
trauma like it great I was bullied
really really early for a whole year and
so I we just live in compounds in Saudi
Arabia and there was a kid who lived on
my compound so there's no escape
he lived in Saudi Arabia I lived all
over the world 14 India Pakistan Greece
Saudi Arabia lemma and he used to bully
me and I I was a coward I was afraid of
him and I did everything I could to
avoid it but I couldn't
so the humiliation of that when I when
you're a small young boy when I was the
firt and I was doing judo and stuff but
the first thing I did when I went to
boarding school was I became a wrestler
cuz I want I I thought I'm gonna get bit
really big and muscular that never
happened but but I became a good
wrestler because I was for a high school
guy but I would have so insecure and I
never wanted to feel that way so the
football players never [ __ ] with me
because I was a wrestler and they were
football players so I never got [ __ ]
with which is a big deal for me it
really matter yeah you know and and but
of course then from there you go on to
doing I did of all the other stuff
because I just wanted to keep building
and are
but that's all because of the trauma I
went through in eighth grade
that's all it's not it's all it's
probably all comes from an unhealthy
place you know you know I still haven't
lost it like I could I would hate if
somebody did that I I know what Brendon
spent with me Brendan's been with me
wear it Brendan Brendan Schaub who can
[ __ ] pull my spine off my head yeah
and we were at we were at a place in the
valley and the guy was we were talking
to these did we were just very
innocently talking these girls
recognized me and they were talking and
stuff and the dude the guy comes up and
starts like like we hitting on the girl
and I thought to myself he doesn't know
he what if that's my girl that's didn't
hear dissing me yeah I don't know one
[ __ ] Brenda don't be embarrassed by him
and say this but like he was like what
are you doing what are you [ __ ] doing
and I yeah I was just yeah it's more
it's more it's more of weird and I slit
his throat I killed him I found gonna
delete this I know dude no I won't I'm
proud of it I I I'm a murderer so that's
the bottom line
yeah when he deserved it I'm sorry yeah
yeah and then and then I had to kill his
friends because they were witnesses and
do you have to kill me cuz you and this
is the old list to me damn it let's
finish the pocket if I just a good knife
oh I know sad yeah
if I keep talking it's gonna sound like
I'm acting like a tough guy and talking
about fights and then I'm gonna get
roasted I'm gonna be very clear I'm a
[ __ ] hear my stories all my fights
no no so am i I'm not if you have any
doubt about my [ __ ] Ness watch please
watch Brendan Schaub and Brian count
fighting on YouTube and you'll get a
sense of what my skill that he's a
professional I mean he's you know he's
so [ __ ] is so strong but I'm I'm
determined and I think I can get I think
I can get position on him and I might
come in on in Crocs and he said he'd put
hands on me I remember I well you always
think you're like more manly I think
some people like things like well he's a
deep voice that would be cool to like
kick his ass and I'm like it but I'm not
strong the physique doesn't match the
voice but you look like an ass you look
at Levesque you could be good at ask you
that man's good at basketball I can like
hit bang shots pretty pretty good I'm
like I'm a good like mid-range shooter
I can hit back
good I bet I'd look good like I see
promise i model my game after like 90s
players but I'm weak so like I grew up
on like the 90s Nick so I'm like yeah
I'm like oak but I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
can't you know so I can hit I can hit
like jump shots pretty consistently but
I can't dribble I'm slow and I'm Way
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue Oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]